[Applaudissements]
ils ont entre 8 et 11 ans et viennent de
s'affronter lors de matchs
d'improvisation théâtrale deux fois par
an la compagnie trappistes et déclic
théâtre organise ces réunions pourront
mettre en avant la jeune génération y en
a qui nous ont rejoints cette année qui
n'ont jamais fait demain d'impro donc
les premières patinoire aussi que les
parents se rendre compte du travail qui
est effectué et que leurs enfants sont
pas longs tu es content d'être là donc
donc voilà c'est la petite réunion du
samedi concentration pendant le briefing
suivi de quelques exercices
d'articulation et de conseils pour les
plus stressés qu'il a de très piètre je
connais bien alors paquet
la première au début on sait le trac et
lecture entre la première fois après sa
passe pas après quelques échauffements
c'est parti pour le lancement des
improvisations
[Musique]
c'est supérieur place et cdma roma
rigoler c'était bien au début on était
stressés mais après être entré dans la
patinoire tout à coup des on est sur la
patinoire
mon sens bac on voit le public donc on a
un peu stressé mais qu'après pense
quelle salle et ben ça va leur première
patinoire donc c'est leur premier match
d'impro et sont très bien débrouillés
ils ont bien mis ils ont bien appliqué
ce qu'ils ont appris en cours après
voilà il ya toujours des choses à à
faire progresser notamment par les plus
forts s'écouter mais voilà donc ça vient
ça vient ça venir avec le temps mais
c'est très bonne première cet après midi
dédié à l'improvisation s'est poursuivie
avec les matchs des cadets et des
juniors